tell me why you're here what are you  doing in this country  this country has always been a place  that people come to find themselves  and to find their dreams  [Music]  the stories of immigrants coming to the  United States are both incredibly unique  but also Universal  [Music]  life is full of comedy and drama and  sometimes those things live side by side  restrictions  [Music]  no  what happens when you come here and you  have a dream  and that dream doesn't work out  everyone struggles and sometimes success  comes in different ways all these women  come into your shop you make them feel  like the best version of themselves  why can't you do that for yourself  [Music]  whether we come here where we grow up  here  I think everybody can see themselves in  these stories  patiency keep you an older business  [Music]  this is such a beautiful portrait of the  tapestry of immigrant experiences in  America it's just oh a nice note and I  love it  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]